hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round three of the W
uh our Chess Masters tournament it's 11
arunan versus
and the game shows just how uh no one is
above the rules no no one is above the
almighty chess principles and uh you'll
see what I mean by this and if you do if
you uh try to break principles against
anyone uh Levon arunan is probably the
worst person you could try to do it
against uh so let's see what happened in
this game uh Levon with the white pieces
opens with E4 we have Pawn to C5 and the
opening choice will be extremely
exciting Knight to F3 we have D6 and now
Pawn to D4 challenging to an open
Sicilian with C characters on D4 Knight
captures and Knight to F6 we have uh
Knight to C3 and now Pawn to G6 another
big goes for the dragon Sicilian and he
uh really wants to show that he can play
at all and that he can play uh for uh a
win against anyone even with the black
pieces and this is a very very sharp
opening if you if you remember in the
olden days Bobby Fischer used to say we
can just put a bishop on E3 Queen to D2
start uh with F3 G4 H4 and then we just
win black black has to resign uh there
is no way to defend against this and
this is uh up to date to the the main
way to plugins the dragon Bishop to E3
Bishop to G7 with F3 at the start of the
Yugoslav attack we have castles and now
Queen to D2 now you will be able to
trade off the dark Square Bishops with
Bishop to H6 with Knight the C6 and now
okay you could uh consider a lot of
moves here like castles Bishop the C4 is
a very nice move
uh you could Advance the pawn to H4 but
we have G4 by level and still nothing
new here Ponte H5 and now Pawn to G5 you
could also play G captures on H5 to try
and uh create a very quick attack
against the black king but Levon wants
to play this positionally uh so uh he
wants to tame the the dragon in the in a
positional Manner and now there is a
game where Knight the D7 was played also
Knights the H7 is a normal but not Rubik
plays Knights to d8 Knight to E8 and it
is now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game uh Lavon castles
Queen side we have Queen to A5 now they
are putting pressure on this queen and
just Knight the B3 uh asking the black
queen to kindly step away but of course
noodle back doesn't do that he goes for
a trade Bishop characters on C3 Knight
captures on A5 with Bishop captures on
D2 with check now Bishop captures you
have to defend your knight here and this
is where the game uh is really really
already concluded now the best way to
play this is probably something like
Knight captures Bishop captures and B6
uh the bishop has to move then you get
rid of the bishop and knight from the
back rank you put maybe The Rook to B8
District to see it and then you start
pushing A6 B5 and so on uh probably the
safest way to play but another big plays
Pawn to F6 and this is uh something that
we often say do not play F6 you are not
not strong no one is strong enough to
play Pawn to F6 there are like a very
few specific positions where it's okay
but in most positions it's not so here
uh Levon plays Knight captures on C6 B
captures on C6 and Okay g captures on F6
we have Knight captures and F6 and now
uh what's the problem with this uh the
weak G6 spawn and now look at this
bishop to H6 goes after The Rook Rook
the E8 or Rook to F7 uh doesn't really
matter and now Bishop to C4 with check
you can see that levon's Bishop Perry is
doing good work here King to H7 and now
Bishop to G G5
also very important just to keep those
those pawns at Bay the G6 Pawn will be a
weakness that livon wants to double up
Brooks and the g file and really go
after that g Pawn but also Bishop to G5
comes with an immediate threat of
winning the pawn just Bishop capture
spawn characters and then you gobble up
the D6 Pawn so here King to G7 now if
captures the king can capture and now
Rook H to G1 how will another big defend
the G6 Pawn we have Pawn to A5 now
preparing to trade off the light Square
Bishops and Rook to G2 preparing up to
double preparing to double up on the G
file Knight's the D7 and now Rook D to
G1 now once the bishop moves the G6 Pawn
will fall so Bishop to A6 first going
after the bishop Bishop to B3 and now
Knight to fade this is how another bag
defends the G6 Pawn uh Bishop back to D2
now it's time to shift the bishop over
to this diagonal we have Bishop back to
C8 you have to counter the light Square
Bishop somehow now and point a for not
allowing a black to play Ponte for so
Levon plays Ponte A4 and pawn to E5 now
you would be you would be very happy to
play something like Bishop to A6 to
trade of the light score Bishops but
then you would have to capture with the
Knight and then the G6 Pawn will be
undefended so here Ponte E5 first by
another back now uh the rook and the
bishop will help out with the defense of
the E6 square and then the Knight can
stay here guarding the G6 Pawn uh but
Bishop to C3 now and now look at the
Bishops here uh true true monsters F4 is
coming there's really no good way to
stop that uh Bishop to E6 now countering
the light core bishop and um there are a
couple of moves you could play here uh
but uh the the one that Lavon plays just
shows how he's a true master of
positional play so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the winning
move for white uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
foreign
played uh interestingly you could play
Rook to D2 or Rook to D1 it's important
to double up Rooks and the D file
doesn't matter in what order you do that
and also it is possible to win the game
with the immediate F4 but uh F4 is the
grind and the move Lavon played that's
uh really an artistic move but I will I
will show the winner with F4 uh point is
that now okay we're threatening to pick
up the Five Pawns so Bishop captures
some B3 C captures and Rook to E6 now
okay the pawn is defended G6 Pawn is
sufficiently defended uh there is Pawn
to F5 and now once you play Rook to F6
you have to keep everything defended uh
Bishop to D2 now you're gonna kick away
the rook and once D5 is played uh Bishop
to G5 and once you move the Rook now
comes Bishop to E7 uh with an attack on
the Knight end The Rook trying to
eliminate the defender of the G6 Pawn
Rook the D7 Bishop captures Rook
captures and now you will play Rook
capture Sun G6 with check and this is
how you win the game King to F7 now you
play B4 of course uh what else would you
play to win the game and now you just
create a pass pawn and it's impossible
to go with something like Rook to A7
because then you just pick up the Rook
the other Rook Rook to 8 is impossible
because just uh for example if Rook date
so if if you go after the the pass Pawn
then just check if you go here this is
Checkmate if you go up the board then we
just deliver a check pick up the Rook so
there's no stopping this a pawn that a
pawn is just uh winning the game so
that's one way to do it but it's it's
really a grind the move the Levon played
Rook to D2 is truly an artistic move uh
and uh there's really nothing for for
black to even try here uh another big
tribe Bishop cat person B3 C captress
and Rook the E6 uh defending the D6
spawn and uh getting ready to meet the
Ponto F4 with a move like Rook to F6 but
now just Rook G to D1 adding another
attacker to the to the D6 pawn and only
now after Rook the d8 Levon plays Pawn
to F4 and now there's no way to to avoid
severe material loss uh here G5 was
played hoping that maybe maybe another
back will uh maybe 11 will take and
another back can at least suffer into a
long end game but Levon just played
Ponte F5 and he was in this position
unmove 31 that notificator resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here uh you really don't know
what's worth Siri if you move from the
defense of the D6 Pawn then we just
gobble it up and that's just it there's
no move black can even make here you
move the Knight Rook is coming to G6
with check the C6 Pawn is hanging the A5
Pawn is saying everything just
completely collapses and another another
thing after F5 if you try something like
Rook the F6 to keep an eye on this Pawn
then Bishop captures an E5 is an instant
resign you either lose this Rook or you
you capture D captures on E5 and then
you lose this Rook there's there's
really nothing
uh so yeah really incredible stuff and
really incredible how another week
really uh boldly went into the dragon
Sicilian and okay he got he got a
playable position but very early on
already on move 14 plays a move like F6
which uh it just gives you a positional
disadvantage against the player like
LaVon arunan that's uh I mean he was
really asking for it and the Levon
really gave it to him uh sure uh that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh do
try the dragon Sicilian from that time
to time it's it's a really an Exquisite
opening you will win a lot of great
victories but you you cannot play moves
like like F6 otherwise your opponents
will uh crush you like like Levon Crush
another back here uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it in in
round four as this was played in round
three in round four all the games ended
in the draw so the one uh keeps the lead
in the tournament uh I would like to
thank bullet King Lindy Brenson
Anonymous
and Joyce Roseman for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day